to turkey where the pandemic weighs on
an already
ailing economy in addition the turkish
lira plunged to almost record levels
after president erdogan fired his third
central bank chief in two years
to install a like-minded critic of high
interest rates
a rate decision is due today
restaurant manager rengen atach is at
his wit's
end the lockdown forced him to shut his
business with its 15
employees for months and now into
ramadan as well
because of rising coronavirus infection
numbers
to make matters worse inflation is
running at a rate of 16 percent per
month
we wanted to invest but we weren't able
to we were too afraid
we don't trust the economy because we
don't know what will happen tomorrow
there is despair and insecurity
a lot of turks have lost faith in their
economy many are unemployed and can
barely afford
anything as the lira's value plummets
shopkeepers and bakers are forced to
constantly raise their prices flour and
other ingredients are becoming more
expensive by the day
the pandemic has also kept tourists away
which for many
was their main source of income
my pockets are empty of course the
crisis affects me
we have no money there's no economy
there's no plan for improving the
situation
they say they have a plan but i don't
see it
the economic situation has affected me i
lost my job during the pandemic like so
many people here
i've been unemployed for about four to
five months now
i earn about 300 a month that's about
the minimum wage
and we're seeing 30 to 40 percent
inflation i've been working the minimum
wage for years
president erdogan has long promised to
boost the economy
and get inflation back under control but
with that ambition looking rather hollow
in march he replaced his third central
bank chief
in just two years we are determined to
bring the rising inflation back to
single digits
we will succeed
but that wasn't the first time erdogan
proclaimed that and the situation still
hasn't improved
will his new central bank chief really
be the game changer everyone hopes for
well that's exactly the question i would
like to ask our correspondent in
istanbul yulia hanzo president erdogan
seems to believe
that rate decision will fix the problems
with the economy so
will the new central bank chief cut
rates today
well that's what he is up to many say
but probably
not today money managers expect turkey's
new central
banker mr kavjolu to hold the key
interest rate steady this month in order
to maintain what's left of
investor confidence he faces a tough
balancing act
he must fix the ailing economy and win
back foreign investors
while keeping president edwan happy as
you mentioned edwin has the unorthodox
view
that higher interest rates cause
inflation instead of slowing it down and
if you recall what happened
to the last central bank governor a
well-respected market-friendly man he
had
hiked the interest rates and was fired a
day later by erdogan
after just four months on the job this
has really left the credibility of the
bank in tatters it had shocked foreign
investors
they pulled out large amounts of money
from turkish stocks and local currency
bonds
but let me also add the current new
central banker is a former lawmaker of
erdogan's ruling akp he seems to share
edwin's unorthodox views of the economy
and that's why many expect him
to go for a rate cut eventually but
sometime
later this year now you mentioned the
unorthodox
view of rate decisions there
would lower rates be good for the
turkish economy
well foreign investors say it would be a
disastrous move because
it would make many problems of the
turkish economy worse
first and foremost inflation as you
mentioned the inflation rate
claimed climbed to more than 16 percent
in march many turks think the actual
rate is much higher they feel it
at every trip to the market because
basic food
items got more and more expensive
rice vegetables sunflower oil eggs
many people also tell me they don't know
how to pay their next rent or their
electricity bill
more than 25 of young people here in the
country
have no job and what i really notice is
that people are not only
frustrated or desperate but they have
lost hope they have completely lost
trust in the economic and fiscal
management
of the country and that certainly also
weighs
on uh erdogan's popularity something
that we will
explore another time julia haan they're
reporting for us
from istanbul thank you so much
you